today nancy pelosi said mlk thomas
jefferson george washington abe lincoln
would all have tears in their eyes
if they knew republicans and two
democrats for preserving the filibuster
you can't make it up take a look
if you really truly
want to honor dr king
don't dishonor him by using a
congressional custom as an excuse for
protecting our democracy he has a
monument on the mall along with abraham
lincoln
george washington
thomas jefferson
all of them
with tears in their eyes for the
departure from our democracy that is
happening right now unless
the truth is acknowledged
and this legislation is passed
if you think nancy pelosi's theatrics
were over the top many other top
democrats they were worse some openly
accusing their fellow democrats that
would be kristen cinema joe manchin now
they're calling their fellow democrats
racist and bigoted take a look people
like joe manchin and kristen cinema
these are the white people that martin
luther king jr warned us about i submit
that members of the senate regardless of
their party
no longer have to ask what we would have
done then
we're doing whatever we would have done
then right now
this is a moral moment
this is a 1965 moment they have sent
this signal they have been very clear
about it they don't care about
minorities they don't care about blacks
they don't care about people in their
own districts who are there going to
deny their voting rights and undermine
their voting rights i know
robert byrd the former senator the late
senator i know what he did in the latter
part of his life yes he was a member of
the ku klux klan but in the latter part
of his life he changed so what i would
say to you is that it is hurting people
the filibuster is hurting people
not to be outdone hillary clinton now
trying desperately to regain relevancy
inserted herself into the conversation
using an mlk quote to trash cinema and
mansion i had hoped that white moderates
would understand that law and order
exist for the purpose of establishing
justice and that when they fail in this
purpose they become the uh the
dangerously structured structured dams
that block the flow of social progress
by the way hillary where were you in the
summer of 2020 we could have used your
help anyway quite a turnaround from the
woman that once referenced african
americans as super predators hillary is
so desperate to be relevant kind of sad
recently democratic strategist james
carville i actually know james like
james have debated james he's not a dumb
guy anyway he had advice for his fellow
liberals quote you democrats my fellow
democrats you whine too much quit being
a whiny party that's an understatement
unfortunately i seriously doubt they
will take his advice and here now with
reaction is the brand new host of the 7
pm hour very proud of him our friend
co-host of the 5 jesse waters along with
fox news contributor leo 2.0 terrell so
far has not made the cut for jesse's
first week but i'm i'm lobbying hard for
you leo i'm i'm on my way
it's going to be hannity leo 2.0
on wednesday not the first show we don't
wait for the first show no first date
first date first day or a lawsuit
lawsuit no first week the first week is
he's making demands it's your first date
just accept it it's his work we live in
an injunction
all right let's start leo you know a
part of this if if democrats didn't use
this playbook so often i might be
offended and might take it seriously but
it just rolls off me like water off a
duck's back because they use it all the
time
well i'll tell you right now look the
democrats have lied to people of color
for 50 years let me just give you two
areas where they lied schools and crime
look at the democratic cities and they
had played the race car for over 50
years they're in a 1965 time warp i've
said this sean for the last year and a
half i want to be clear there is no
systemic racism in this country dr king
eliminated that with the voting right
act the civil rights act and the fair
housing act but the democrats will keep
reinventing the race card you know what
it is now it's critical race theory but
if you look at the polls it's not just
joe biden is shrinking in the polls he's
losing black support and hispanic
support because people of color of all
colors they have woke
they're awake they know they don't drink
the democratic kool-aid anymore and
that's why you see the democrats in
trouble and very very desperate you know
jess you forget the playbook for a
second here let's look at other issues
we have in democratic blue states blue
cities we have crime wave after crime
wave a result of no bail laws a result
of
get rid of the cops steve fund dismantle
and i look at that if you can't
keep law and order and people safe and
secure so they can pursue happiness you
look at the school systems they're
destroying our children we spend more
per capita on education per student with
the worst results now we're going to
trust them to take over every other
aspect of our life the same people that
bankrupted social security the ones that
said keep your doctor plan and save
money those people why do people trust
a party that has lied and failed again
and again
well they don't the american people have
turned on the democratic party because
the democratic party has turned on the
american people we want to be focused on
inflation and the economy not windmills
and mail-in ballots and now that the
biden agenda has stalled out the
democratic party is turning on
themselves many democrats especially
black democrats feel like they delivered
the nomination to joe biden but biden
hasn't delivered
anything to them so they're trying to
nuke through their entire wish list and
are fragging moderate democrats with
vicious racial slander who don't want to
go along with their destructive power
grab as you showed crooked is getting in
the trenches which tells me she's going
to make a run in 2004 nancy pelosi so
bewildered she's invoking the founding
fathers in a good way to shame her
fellow democrats and i don't think the
shame game or the race the question this
way with mansion and cinema at all why
do these blue states again they can't
provide simple law and order safety and
security or a good education for our
kids keep it simple
everything about obamacare was a lie
keep it simple
but they keep getting elected in these
same states and cities why
well they have a machine in these blue
cities sean you know how that works it's
overwhelming
go ahead 2.0
thank you very much they have they have
they have created a dependency they have
created a lie saying that there is a
half of this country that is racist
white supremacist they misguided the
whole country on that terrorist attack
last over the weekend why because they
want to focus on white supremacy they
don't want to focus on what's going on
overseas with terrorism and the context
of what's going on in this country
borderless country they want to keep
that white supremacy card played and
they're trying to point the finger at
everyone else but themselves the
democrats are the racist organization
the party of racism
jesse we'll give you the last word
well biden has a pivotal news conference
on wednesday i don't think it's
physically possible for him to do
anything to turn this around it's like
me trying to dunk a basketball i just
can't do it
the scandals in his administration
are gobbling up huge chunks of people's
paychecks it's getting people fired it's
delaying flights it's making the streets
less safe it's literally hurting people
it's not like yo benghazi irs whitewater
people sit back on their couch and they
follow it on the tv and they watch the
media spin the media can't spin their
way out of this the democrats can't spin
their way out of this he is an
impossible hole right now and like i
said he is physically incapable of
getting himself out all right jesse
waters again congratulations on your new
show